Let's go through each one of these before we find our answer. Mu minus x will
give us a positive number because mu is larger than x in both cases, so that's
the first thing we did. But that doesn't tell us how many standard deviations
away from the mean x is, x minus mu will give us the opposite of this one. Which
is basically the negative distance, x minus mu times sigma doesn't really make
sense. That would be multiplying thins distance by this standard deviation, x
minus mu divided by sigma is closer to what we did, but this will give us the
negative distance. However, later you'll see that this equation is very
important. And again, we didn't multiply by sigma. So, this is the correct
answer to find just how far in terms of standard deviations x is from the mean.
We found the distance which is mu minus X, and then we divide it by the standard
deviation.